[Music]
what if policies make indivisible rights
visible to all EU citizens but if
legislation makes rules more relevant to
our common values what if this makes
people the priority of our law and
policymaking all by using the Charter of
Fundamental Rights since 2009 the
Charter has served as an essential tool
in turning EU citizens rights into
reality as a result we've advanced our
laws and policies as the EU has adopted
many initiatives to protect and promote
people's rights but now is a time to
take them even further with over 50
articles the Charter is a legally
binding modern Human Rights catalogue
that enriches existing entitlements it's
profound phrasing goes beyond many
constitutional texts it can inspire law
and policy makers to develop more
sustainable and better legislation and
where States regions or municipalities
are acting on matters where the EU has a
say the Charter turns to a soft
aspiration into hard laws to the
benefits of all of us
[Music]
the chanter helps you to make
indivisible rights visible rules all
relevant people the priority apply the
Charter deliver our rights
you
good morning first of all warm thanks to
fundamental rights agency for preparing
this video it really sets a good tone
for the day it puts the Charter into
spotlight so dear ministers ambassadors
judges lawyers members of parliament
representatives of civil society
organisations in academia and of course
right defenders or behalf of the
Commission and our code organizers
finished presidency and the fundamental
rights agency I'm really happy to wish
you warmly welcome to this conference
which marks the tenth anniversary of the
Charter becoming legally binding you are
all what we like to call actors in the
charters enforcement chain you play a
key role in making charter a reality in
people's lives and today you will have
the opportunity to gather reflect on how
to use charter to its full potential
today we put the Charter and the rights
and values it didn't rise really in the
spotlight and during the breaks you can
wander around and discover the work of
Sylvia and Stefan two artists who have
taken the Charter to ten places your
German cities in the marketplaces asking
citizens to improve or what their
improvements would be to various
articles of the Charter I think this is
a very nice and innovative way to raise
a resilience awareness of the Charter
Sylvia Stefan will be here presents in
the afternoon and present their work we
have also set a a photo booth next door
where you can take selfies of your
favorite or in front of your favor
it charter right and I would encourage
you to participate in this and
disseminate the pictures in your own
networks the hashtag for today is
hashtag EU Charter over lunchtime
colleagues from the Commission and the
agency will present also the Charter
online tools such as the European a
justice portal charter pedia and
European fundamental rights information
systems so the presentations will be
held in English and take place in this
room so please feel free to attend that
presentation please also note that the
whole event will be web streamed and
that interpretation is available from an
to English French German Italian and
polish from now until quarter past
twelve and then again from quarter past
two to half past six and now to the
program I would like to welcome
commissioner era yerba commissioner
Europa has been working hard
under the current Commission to promote
and protect fundamental rights in the EU
and we are very happy that she will be
continuing her work under the new
Commission as vice president for values
and transparency please commissioner
Thank You Tina you just just reminded me
that in fact my favorite a fundamental
right is the right to be forgotten which
I will not manage by continuing in the
Commission so we will be happy to
cooperate further in the next five years
I hope ladies and gentlemen dear
colleagues dear friends co-operators in
the field of human rights Michael my
honor I am really very honored to be
today with you as we mark the 10th
anniversary of the EU Charter of
Fundamental Rights becoming wrigley
binding the video just reminded us that
we can achieve a lot if we do the things
right if we try hard we actually can
achieve something substantial if we fail
we will fail everything and I think that
this is a very strong push for all of us
to continue what we are doing and be
courageous and be hard-working the
Charter itself is already a great
achievement as the Charter we agreed on
a set of shared values and fundamental
rights that serve as a compass to guide
our actions the Charter as a symbol of
our shared European identity the
knowledge that we are belong to that we
all belong to a community of values
where fundamental rights are respected
where democracy and the rule of law
prevail it also represents an important
milestone in the development of the EU
the leap from what was essentially an
economic Union to one that puts its
citizens
at its heart it might be easier to
realize the value of the Charter if we
recall the past this November
we celebrate the anniversary of the
Velvet Revolution in former
Czechoslovakia and the thirties
anniversary of the fall of the Berlin
Wall
these were acts not only symbolic of the
collapse of the oppressive communist
system in Eastern and Central Europe but
of the desire of the oppressed to be
part of such a community of values the
Charter is the representation of
freedoms we on the east of the iron wall
thoughtful but we have to be honest the
everyday life in Europe does not always
reflect the ideal captured in the
Charter everyday people entire groups
are discriminated against we see laws
that limit people's rights we see
technologies that make the application
of fundamental rights very difficult to
few Europeans know and understand their
rights too many feel they remain on
paper and don't apply in real life so we
have a duty to act and to change this
before I apply some ideas of what I
would like to do it's important to
understand where we came from and what
happened over the past 10 years
over the past decade the Charter has led
to a more coherent and comprehensive
interpretation of fundamental rights
across the EU this included putting new
rights forward
take for instance already mentioned
right to be forgotten interpreting the
right to privacy in the digital age
this is now clearly part of our privacy
rules set but this also meant ensuring
fundamental rights are protected in
whatever initiative we take from my work
on this in the current Commission I can
tell you that we have collectively put a
lot of efforts to ensure charter
compliance this has not always been easy
particularly when preparing legislation
in the field of migration or security
but the awareness about the Charter and
the decision-making is reality
what's more the court of justice of the
EU has been instrumental in developing a
culture of fundamental rights withing
the institution's
I am sure you will hear more about this
later from the best possible speaker the
president Leonard's a fine and
well-informed he is coming this
afternoon so now we have a strong body
of EU law that proactively promotes and
protects citizens rights the new rules
on data protection gender equality and
on protecting whistleblowers and victims
of crime are just a few examples the
last decade also witnessed the emergence
of a vibrant scene of defenders of
fundamental rights such as National
Human Rights institutions equality
bodies on both persons as well as civil
society organizations and networks they
are crucial as our eyes and ears on the
ground and they are often the first
instance to turn for the victims of
fundamental rights abuses there is
however one important lesson the general
consensus in the EU around fundamental
rights and values can never be taken for
granted
the increased uncertainty of many
Europeans over security
jobs migration climate change or
technological transformation create a
fertile ground for autocrats and
political extremists they offer a false
choice between security and rights so I
want to be clear on this there will be
no freedom and security if we sacrifice
our rights we have to fight this false
premise and get better in showing to
people that the foundation of security
and prosperity are the values enshrined
in the Charter this is why now more than
ever it is essential to make the
benefits of the Charter clear for all
fundamental rights matter in our
societies because they put the
individual in the center stage and they
are about recognizing and protecting
that individual in his or her own way we
need to ensure that the principles
rights and values enshrined in the
Charter are not perceived as empty
promises but rather that they become a
reality for all the clear message from
the Eurobarometer survey was that our
citizens want to know more about their
rights and where to turn to if these
rights are violated rights are important
but they also need to be effectively
enforced many of you in this room are
instrumental in bringing the Charter to
life you are all part of the charters
enforcement chain ensuring it has a real
impact on people's lives by being
applied effectively it is not always
easy to understand when and how the
Charter applies the rights enshrined in
the Charter are
not self-standing they apply only for
the implementation of EU law that means
that when citizens come to us with
concerns over their rights we often had
to tell them that it is not within our
remit to help them we of course point
them in the right direction usually
towards national institutions but this
kind of response can of course be
frustrating for both sides for those who
come to us with hopes but also for us
who have to say go somewhere else
but we are telling them this trust that
at the national level the complaints
will be hurt and solved what we do what
we would like to achieve today is to
find ways to use the Charter to its full
potential and to make it more relevant
as I mentioned during my recent hearing
before the European Parliament in the
new Commission mandate
I intend to revise the Charter strategy
that was adopted ten years ago for this
I would gladly welcome your inputs and
your ideas allow me share some initial
thoughts with you of the areas where I
would like to act first we have to
continue putting the human dimension at
the core of the EU s legislative and
policy work for example with artificial
intelligence or minimum wage priorities
announced already by President Elect
secondly I would like to improve the
assessment of the state of play of
fundamental rights so far we have done
half of the job looking at how it works
at the EU level but if we are to read
the benefits to the citizens the key
I am afraid is at the member state level
third in the effective application of
the rights once we understand where the
problems we are
are we have to use all the tools at our
disposal be it legal or political to
ensure that the rights are there for
everyone we have to look at the whole
enforcement chain from the Commission
through the court to the Human Rights
Institute and strengthen the weaker link
links force we have to evaluate impact
of current trends on the application of
fundamental rights there might be cases
more substantial guidance from our side
might be needed I think in particular
about the digital world as the last year
last year's show big challenges when it
comes to upholding the basic rights
online including dignity freedom of
expression or even free elections last
but not least awareness of Rights let me
stress of rights rather than only of the
Charter itself people have to know
what's in the book not only the cover if
we want them to effectively use it one
key objective of the new strategy should
be to enhance support for those who who
right that are violated and to help them
understand where they can turn to help
and what they can do of course these are
just some initial thoughts and I hope
this event and many others will help us
to find the best way forward we will do
this in an inclusive way involving all
key actors at the national and European
level in the process ladies and
gentlemen dear colleagues dear friends
now at the beginning of a new EU policy
cycle is the
perfect moment to refocus our efforts
and to put the chart at the center of
our action you the actors of change are
integral and as I said before very
instrumental to this I wish you a
successful conference and thank you
ahead for your inputs for our future
work especially on the strategy for
implementing the Charter better thank
you very much
thank you very much commissioner and now
I would like to invite Annamayya
Hendrickson who is the Minister of
Justice in Finland she is a strong
proponent of fundamental rights and I'm
very pleased to to have been able to
serve for her during her previous
mandate as a Minister of Justice in
Finland
she taught me something and I thought
that I think her mother had taught it to
her and that is when you have a reason
to celebrate do it and I think we are
here we have a reason we have the ten
years where the Charter has been legally
binding but I think we can also
celebrate the future work that we are
doing please
Thank You Tina for your kind words and
good morning everyone
vice-president designate Yoruba dear
Vera
director of latterly they are Michael
they're participants ladies and
gentlemen it's my great pleasure to be
here today with you to celebrate the
10th anniversary or the fundamental
rights charter as a legally binding
document the fact that the anniversary
falls during Finland's presidency of the
Council of the EU is a pleasant
coincidence promoting fundamental rights
has been a long-standing priority of
Finland's EU policy fundamental rights
are also an important part of the
Finnish presidency program and on behalf
of the Finnish presidency unhappy to
wish you all warmly welcome to this
conference respect for our common values
is the backbone of the EU this has been
highlighted throughout Finland's
presidency democracy the rule of law and
the fundamental rights the famous triple
are interlinked and interdependent if
one is missing the home triple falls
down and we are now talking about we are
not talking about luxury items that
people living in the EU enjoy only on
good days but about the very foundations
of our societies this is important to
keep in mind when talking about
fundamental rights their promotion and
protection is even more essential in
turbulent times
we encounter new challenges such as
increase of online hate speech
this requires robust action by all of us
both at the national and the EU level
freedom of speech is a precondition for
a Democrat the for a Democratic Society
hate speech hampers the full realization
of Rights and it is not protected by the
freedom of speech on the contrary it can
limit the access to information and the
principle of non-discrimination and we
know that hate speech may also in
extreme cases lead to hate crime dear
guests at the EU level the Charter is
our core fundamental rights instrument
the EU s own Bill of Rights it is still
relatively young fundamental rights
instrument at least if compared to UN
conventions or the European Convention
on Human Rights
however it's becoming more widely used
and no I think that it's finally gaining
the role it deserves
yet more needs to be done to reach its
full potential and to fully realize the
rights enshrined in the Charter
therefore it's important to enhance the
use the Charter at the national level as
a member of Swedish speaking minority in
Finland I know how important fundamental
rights are to all of us today we are
celebrating the 10th anniversary of the
Charter becoming legally binding upon
the entry into force or the Lisbon
Treaty in 2009 next year
we will
vibrating the 20th anniversary of the
Charter since it was drafted by the
European Convention and solemnly
proclaimed in 2000 we have colleagues
among us who have followed the entire
lifecycle of the Charter so far we have
witnessed great developments regarding
charter awareness at the national level
resulting in its increased use and yet
there are still people in the European
Union who have never even heard about
the Charter this means we all have a
role to play in the enforcement of the
charter action is needed at both the EU
level as well as the national level here
I would like to mention the important
set of council conclusions conclusions
conclusions on the 10th anniversary of
the Charter adopted on the 7 October
this year the conclusions highlight the
importance of the charters used by all
relevant actors in particular the
conclusions make an explicit mention of
the council itself alongside with member
states the Commission the fundamental
rights agency National Human Rights
institutions and other bodies as
relevant actors in applying the Charter
that covers many of us here today the
role of the courts both at the European
as well as at the national level is
crucial the conclusions underline the
importance of the case law of the Court
of Justice of the European Union and the
growing role played by national courts
in securing the effectiveness of the
Charter in addition I would like to
highlight the important role
or national parliaments and that of the
academia short compiled compliant
legislation is in the hands of the
parliaments the academia can help in
both ensuring that new lawyers are
familiar with the Charter as well as
providing up-to-date legal research on
the Charter the council concerns new
conclusions on the Charter include a
number of concrete measures by which we
can enhance implementation of the
Charter vice-president designate Urawa
has already mentioned some of them here
today
the Commission's charter strategy is of
particular importance and we welcome the
Commission's efforts on this I'm also
happy about the introduction of an
annual Charter exchange at the expert
level at the working party on
fundamental rights citizens rights and
free movement of persons this kind of
sharing of best practices between the
Member States on the use of the Charter
is extremely important ladies and
gentlemen all branches of the government
are needed the executed the legislative
and the judicial they each have their
own role but fundamental rights are
nevertheless important in all of them
the use of public power is by nature
fundamental rights sensitive I would
like to share with you some of our
experiences in Finland in ensuring
charter compliance in legislation and in
public administration the Finnish system
assesses the constitutionality of
proposed legal acts beforehand
the assessment includes compliance with
our Constitution but also with Finland's
international human rights obligations
Lord rottens are given guidance on how
to take fundamental and human rights in
consideration when drafting new
legislation at the government level the
Chancellor of Justice oversees the
legality of government action including
law proposals at the Finnish Parliament
the Constitutional Law Committee
considers law proposals from the
perspective of the Constitution but also
with respect to other fundamental and
human rights obligations the Parliament
has to take the views of the committee
into consideration all these steps aim
at ensuring that all pieces of
legislation are in line with fundamental
and human rights including the Charter
however we also need the possibility for
exposed assessment in particular by the
courts in individual cases all members
of the legal family need to be aware of
the Charter rights and their impact on
national legislation the role of legal
practice is particularly important we
have had good experience this from the
Charter specific training that we have
provided to civil servants in January to
Ministry of Justice organized a one-day
training for government officials on the
Charter with particular emphasis on data
protection we received extremely
positive feedback and requests for more
training on EU fundamental rights in
preparation for the EU presidency we
have also trained our own EU staff at
the permanent representation
in Brussels on the Charter in good
cooperation with the council Secretariat
and the fundamental rights agency dear
friends with these positive notes I
would like to finish my speech by
underlining you need to be pragmatic the
Charter may still need support from its
whole enforcement chain in order to be
fully integrated in all relevant acts
and activities but this support does not
need to be rocket science we need better
awareness and we need concrete tools the
conference today will provide both in
addition this is an important
opportunity for the key players at the
EU level to come together and discuss
how to ensure that the crown jewel of
the EU legislation the Charter of
Fundamental Rights gets the attention it
deserves this policy cycle with the new
Commission is an opportune time to look
for new initiatives I'm very much
looking forward to working with the new
Commission in promoting fundamental
rights and I am confident that this task
is in good hands let's continue working
together to further enhance charter
implementation Finland we will be a part
of these efforts also after our EU
presidency and together we can develop a
culture of fundamental rights across the
Union last but not least I would like to
thank the Commission and the fundamental
rights agency for the excellent
cooperation in the preparations of this
joint conference and you will hear a
number of interesting presentations and
her number of interesting discussions
and also take part it
in it today and I wish you all a very
good and fruitful conference thank you
for your attention thank you
and now I would like to invite the third
speaker of this introductory session to
join me a Michael O'Flaherty Michael is
really the face and the voice of the
European agency of Fundamental Rights
and we have been joining forces to work
together to develop in cultural
fundamental rights in the EU and the
data that the agency provides on the
situation of fundamental rights on the
ground is really the key to our both
legislative and policy work at the
European national level and I'm
extremely happy that we have been able
to work on for this conference together
so please Michael
Dina thank you very much for that kind
introduction
Minister Commissioner ambassadors judges
dear colleagues let me join in welcoming
you warmly today it has been such a
great pleasure to work with the
Commission and with the Finnish
presidency to pull together today's
event and we're honored that so many of
you are here with us I read the
participants list earlier this morning
and I was both deeply impressed and
daunted by the expertise and the
experience that has been gathered here
for today's discussions dear friends
when I was applying for this job I spent
a bit of time in the European Parliament
a lot of it just hanging around and on
one of those visits on the third floor I
came across a display case which rather
impressed me it was a display case
containing one of the original signed
versions of the Charter of Fundamental
Rights
however on close inspection I was
horrified because as those of you who
will have seen the case will know the
Charter was quite literally disappearing
it was under a heavy beam of sunlight
and the ink was fading by the day now I
can't help but think that that
experience of what is seeing that
document in the Parliament had something
to say to today
something to say if not about an ever
more invisible charter but at least of a
charter that is not sufficiently visible
in our work and in our societies and
today then can be acknowledged as a day
of not just celebration of 10 years and
certainly that but also a wake-up call
to reinvigorate our attention to the
focus on the Charter but it's useful
just to take a minute before looking at
what we need to do to reflect on what
the Charter itself is Minister just now
described it as a crown jewel that's a I
think a beautiful way to put it I was
going to say Magna Carta but it's the
same point
it is an extraordinary human rights
tour-de-force and ultimately it's not
about law it's about people it's about
everybody within the European Union
it's about those migrants that were so
worried about currently on the Greek
islands it's about the Roma in villages
across Europe who go to bed hungry
it's about our older relatives suffering
in appropriate treatment in nursing
homes across our societies it's about
all of us in the protection of our
personal data and as the Charter seeks
to deliver for all of us it does so in
ways that are truly notable in the first
place we must never forget the status of
the Charter unlike human rights treaties
transnational human rights treaties the
Charter is Supra national meaning it has
domestic effect when EU law applies in
our Parliament's and in our courtrooms
with that domestic effect it's also
extremely interesting to acknowledge the
extent to which the guarantees in the
Charter go beyond the guarantees we find
in many of our national constitutions we
did a study last year on exactly this
question and we were rather taken aback
by the extent to which the Charter
delivered in in many ways that were
neglected or not addressed in national
constitutions
and third in terms of the power of this
instrument it does what typically was
not achieved especially well in the
negotiation of human rights treaties in
that it brings together civil and
political together with economic social
and cultural rights and finally and
indeed going back to that point about
its comparison to constitutional rights
it's a very modern catalog of
fundamental rights just to take a few
examples it contains a right of good
administration you won't find that in
other human rights instruments its
guarantees if for the administration of
justice are far stronger than those
you'll find in the human
treaty's it contains an explicit
protection of personal data it's the
only human rights instrument with an
explicit right to asylum
it contains the highly innovative right
to conduct a business and explicit
consumer protection rights but how well
are we doing
I would like to dwell if I may and
complement what we've heard from the
Minister and the Commissioner I would
like to focus on the national level it's
something we're following constantly in
the fundamental rights agency year by
year examining the impact of the Charter
and its engagement by key professional
groups above all judges and lawyers and
what we've mapped there over the years
is a modest growth in its use in its
invocation in its application at the
national level but let's be honest from
a rather low base and we don't like to
have anything like the level of
engagement that we would want to see and
we see also in particularly in terms of
its use in courts that while sometimes
the use is smart and clever innovative
and impactful on other occasions it's
superficial or even in some cases
mistaken why is that why do the mistakes
sometimes get made why is the level of
use so low well we know from repeated
questioning of the relevant
professionals that it comes back time
and time again to issues of low levels
of knowledge of the Charter and sincere
uncertainty about its scope of
application for example there's
confusion about the relative status of
its rights and its principles and of
course as always the business are the
issue rather of when a matter is
actually one of you competence or not
turning from the courts to Parliament's
again here I'm afraid we don't have much
to show the finish superb good practice
that we heard about from the minister is
unfortunately an exceedingly rare good
practice it's not replicated in many EU
Member States moving from Parliament to
Human Rights civil society and National
Human Rights institutions today the
fundamental rights agency is publishing
a paper for this conference drawing
findings from an engagement with civil
society with NHGRI's to test their
levels of awareness and use and these
findings more or less replicate the
findings in other sectors just one in
four twenty five percent of the
respondent organizations invoke the
Charter periodically in their work one
in ten have never invoked the Charter in
any aspect of their work so again a job
to be done with civil society we of
course also identified some really
interesting good practice within civil
society and National Human Rights
institutions for example the Czech
public defender of Rights repeatedly
invokes the Charter on behalf of
individual rights holders and one last
point about civil society is what they
had to tell us about government
we asked civil society and nhr eyes to
tell us about national action planning
by governments in their country for
promotion of the Charter and they told
us they were not aware of any such
action plan and finally there is the
issue of the levels of awareness in the
general public now I agree with previous
speakers that these figures are very low
and they need to be improved but to be
honest with you I'm not massively
concerned right now the Charter as we
heard this morning is a new instrument
it's just a decade in force as a legal
binding document and I'm not sure
anybody here can think back to 1963 but
that was the tenth anniversary of the
European Convention on Human Rights and
I wonder how many people knew about the
European Convention in 1963 so we have
time and I believe that as the
professional groups at the front line
grow an awareness of use of the
instrument it will become better known
in our societies and now before turning
in conclusion to some specific action
points please allow me a word a word on
the particular role of the European
Court of Justice
it's important from the outset today to
acknowledge that the ECJ is a primary
agent the crucial agent for building up
the impact and the use of the Charter
also at the national level and I would
suggest you this morning that we here in
the European Union can be proud of the
European Court of Justice it has
demonstrated judicial rigor firmly
grounded in human and fundamental rights
and it's a very elegant coincidence to
use the minister's word it's an elegant
coincidence that today is the 60th
anniversary of the delivery by the court
of the stander judgment which held that
and I quote fundamental human rights are
enshrined in the general principles of
community law and are protected by the
court and in the 60 years since under
the court has persistently insistently
have built up its jurisprudence it's a
key in the area of human and fundamental
rights including with regard to the
Charter and to evidence the extent to
which the court engages the Charter just
take one among so many possible figures
in 2013 there were 100 references to the
Charter in judgments of the court in
2018 that figure had risen to an
astonishing 350 an hour let me in
conclusion turn to some specific action
points but before doing so I would have
to say I couldn't help but be deeply
impressed by what Commissioner you're
ever said to us this morning she laid
out a broad big-picture action plan for
embedding human and fundamental rights
at the heart of our societies I want to
tell you commissioner that you will have
the unstinting 100 percent support of
the fundamental rights agency in
delivering on this fantastic vision and
what I will say now are narrow points
embedded in that much larger story the
fundamental rights agency today would
call on three initiatives to deliver
better impact of the Charter at the
national level
in the first place we would ask our
governments of our Member States to
become champions of the Charter let's be
frank we don't have too many national
level governmental champions of the
Charter at the present time I make that
call in the particular context of
article 51 of the Charter which calls on
member states and the other Duty bearers
to respect and to promote and to protect
rather but also to promote the charger
and it's in the spirit of promoting the
Charter whether that called for
promotion as a legal duty or not in the
spirit of that call that Member States
developed those action plans I referred
to earlier bringing together all of the
national energy to make the difference
secondly we would ask that more
attention be given to training at the
national level on the use of the Charter
and let me say at the outset here of
course that we deeply appreciate the
persistent leadership of the Commission
in seeking to promote a far higher level
of training and awareness raising and I
applaud the achievements of the European
judicial training Network in that regard
but I think everybody would agree that
we still have a long way to go at the
national level in embedding the Charter
in our academic and our professional
curricula and third and finally we at
the fundamental rights agency would call
for a better use of all of the Charter
typically it's engaged with regard to
Civil and Political Rights 90% of the
invitations of the Charter in the
European Court of Justice in 2018
referred to civil and political rights
just 10% to the area of socio economic
justice and above all now as we struggle
with rising levels of inequality in
European society now is a moment at two
to breathe more and better life into the
full breadth of the Charter including in
this area of socio-economic rights until
the spirit of that broadening of our
engagement that I'm so very pleased to
inform you that this morning
the heads of all of the EU agencies in
the field of justice and Home Affairs
have come together to adopt a
declaration and to the effect that they
will embed the Charter across every
aspect of all of their work and so dear
friends as we all go forward together in
our work of promoting the Charter please
count on the continued support of the
fundamental rights agency we will
deliver that in two ways in the first
place we will continue to develop and
publish discrete tools to assist you in
this endeavor our annual report will
continue to have a dedicated focus
chapter every year on the application of
the Charter across the member states we
have published this year country fact
sheets which bed down the application of
the Charter for each member state in the
particular constitutional context of it
third last year we published a handbook
for lawmakers on how to apply the
Charter in their work and frankly the
the handbook is transferable from
lawmakers to judges and to all other
legal practitioners we have now for a
number of years and we will continue to
maintain and improve the so-called
Charter pedia which is an online
resource of every imaginable judgement
finding a piece of academic writing with
regard to the application of the Charter
and today we're publishing two new tools
one of those is charmingly called the
Charter box and the Charter box is a
tool targeted specifically to members of
the European Parliament it's being
delivered to them today and it contains
all of the the tools the equipment the
materials that we believe that they need
in order to embed the Charter across all
of their work and secondly and finally
in terms of new tools today we will
launch a new instrument called the
European fundamental rights information
system so-called Efes FRS is an online
resource which for the first time ever
globally will bring together all of the
findings of all of the international
monitoring bodies in the
Human Rights filled country-by-country
right by right and the efforts is
organized according to the chapters and
the categories of the Charter secondly
and finally in terms of how we will
support you we will continue to ensure
that the Charter informs everything that
we do the Charter is our grund norm it
is the legal base on which from which we
start all of our research and our
technical assistance activities it is
also increasingly the heart of our
programs of cooperation with civil
society with National Human Rights
institutions with governments indeed and
with equality bodies and so dear friends
thank you very much for your attention
this morning let me go back in absolute
conclusion to the to the display box at
the Parliament it's not there anymore
it was taken away at some point last
year it was taken away so that the
document itself could be restored that's
find in that also an image for today
today is an opportunity for all of us to
restore ourselves to restore our passion
for our commitment to the Charter of
Fundamental Rights to ensure that it
becomes what its drafters dreamt of the
beating heart of our European project
thank you